[Music]
in the gangster life chose me news
submitted by forged Murray Minh that's
good for getting Freeman Oh
an 81 year old man got caught up in a
crime out of boredom 81 oh I get it
actually more like cattle only yeah so
he wanted a good you know they're dead
go 81 bro train was dead to me go to
jail for just annoying somebody like
photographer I wish yeah so this 81 year
old has been jailed for nine months as a
getaway driver for a man who's accused
of stabbing a rival in a dispute over
drugs holy [ __ ]
so this man's name is Ian he picked up
Mohammed after an attack in the UK and
so they're saying that so he's a retired
burger van driver maybe he just
should've [ __ ] started doing over or
something because I think I could be
wrong but I think for uh to be a taxi
driver in England you have to be able to
like memorise streets and like the math
and stuff so it's actually a very
extensive process you're walking around
I mean I I saw this somewhere I could be
I could be lying but still maybe back in
the day maybe not good at mafia no try
me anyways yeah so look his
co-defendants who's this 23 year old
named Hakeem he was jailed for nine
years for wounding with intent and two
charges of possessing cocaine and heroin
with intent to supply so what ended up
happening here is that Ian he was just
driving and he ended up seeing these two
guys are trying to hitchhike so he
picked them up portable but no he
- like you know assist them and like
they're claiming that he even helped the
dude that ended up doing the stabbing
who stabbed his victims boy yeah
so he's like what you guys doing like oh
we're out murder and then he's like oh
well I'll Drive for you if he I'm kind
of lonely yeah stab him there's mm I
mean he could be a [ __ ] psychopath
that's like what the bucket list getaway
driver yeah so the judge said you
assisted an offender by driving him away
from the scene when you knew he must
have been involved in a serious assault
you saw blood on Hamming you undoubtedly
knew that he had been involved in drug
dealing but your involvement was
considerably more than this one journey
you made several journeys on that day
and on that night before you would have
been aware that you were being used as a
driver whose age and appearance would
have been unlikely to draw attention so
you're saying that he helped them like
escape to a different country this is
what Ian looks like 81 he looks like a
gangster he looks like a ghost from the
crisp this guy looks like she's a part
of the [ __ ] British mob people yeah I
get it I don't know how with no teeth
good point he turns him into a soup that
fool got no teeth he blends him that
might have been in he wanted parts of a
dead body or the person who got stabbed
so he could eat him later he just looks
like a thug to me no he's like really I
don't see that I see this guy at a
gambling den I see this guy at a strip
club he's owning [ __ ] shady hotels
and brothels I he's a mobster if I was
in the jury I didn't need to hear
anything I see him like guilty
yeah right off the bat yeah he doesn't
look caught off guard I don't know I
kind of feel for him because I know
because actually I did meet someone once
that said that they were a getaway
driver for a heinous crime but they
didn't know the person well you never
told us this [ __ ] yeah what kind of
friends are we yeah well now you're not
brought up before it's just like I'm
gonna tell you when we're at this ball
make it no [ __ ] do you know of course
what was the context hey I used to be a
getaway driver TIFF anyway I like your
cherry marmalade time in jail and I
asked him like well why were you in jail
for and then they were like oh it's just
it's I didn't even know this but I was
driving my friends and they pulled like
they asked me to pull over I thought
they were gonna pick up some cigarettes
they ended up assaulting a man and
stabbing him similar to this actually
how many how many is that guy in jail or
two I didn't know yeah so then he was
just like I didn't know like yeah they
ended up telling me like okay let's just
go so he was just driving that's when
they got pulled over and then he was
just get the [ __ ] out of my car kind of
thing he was supposed to be like that I
don't know these were his friend hmm but
he didn't know this guy didn't know yeah
well I don't know how much he knew but
they're saying that he saw blood made
him happy check my wife used to bleed I
once a month right I have zero
compassion for all peoples why because
they had a lot of time to get it
together and they still [ __ ] up I
have even more hate for them all right
yeah
even more it no cuz I mean like okay so
so if you're old and lonely and [ __ ]
right that means you're a [ __ ]
[ __ ] when you were a parent that's
your [ __ ] dick we only had one kid
that kid died yeah we're thinking wrong
with my transmen you've had a long time
to pop out multiple kids well there's a
smart kid to get hit but yours there's
circumstances right like there might be
a sweet old person but there's a reason
why they're alone a big good reason it's
probably because they're a [ __ ] not
because whenever they lost their whole
family the tornado that's different yeah
but
then I mean that situation sucks but at
the same time like you have a chance to
make friends with other people your age
or don't live in tornado alley or
something tornado alley yeah and usually
social people and and nice people they
can just go right back and [ __ ] find
a whole new camp you know and if they're
old and lonely you are probably a
[ __ ] all your [ __ ] life so you
deserve that [ __ ] yeah damn I hope you
never know I'll never be old and lonely
because you guys will be forever around
no you don't even call his friends in
public are you talking about if I use
the [ __ ] out of you and that's all I
need you for never lonely you renounced
your friendship with us in front of
people I did yeah more times no you
don't believe what you hear from my
mouth because that's not the truth okay
hmm yeah supposed to believe what you
just said you're gonna suss it out
sounds like sounds like a wedding
crashes like you don't believe that I
feel like I've insured my future with
y'all nope so I can go away for 10 years
no come back
[ __ ] and still use the [ __ ] out of you
guys cuz I've done enough investing so
stretch strategically I think I've done
enough to where I'm gonna be able to
lean on them and use them for the rest
of my life what's the biggest investment
you've done for these people gave their
[ __ ] dreams a reality thing yeah I
made it all happen they didn't do
anything on their own there before they
met me there are a bunch of complete
losers that had nothing going for them
right yeah you really secured the bank
dude and I picked them up out of the
dumpster this feels good and I built
them up completely you know what I have
to say it cuz I never get the the thanks
and the support that I should get so
what ends up happening is obviously the
the nonprofit organization that I
created for these lonely [ __ ] called
was Joe's heaven mm-hmm right Joe's
charity work I I did this for them
because I care so much from her can I
hate to see losers be losers but I did a
lot of this and built this for them all
by myself
they still never give me any credit for
it or thank-you or anything but I'm
there because I'm there because I care
but can you tell them about the porn
that you like where girls have huge
[ __ ] and they that one have you seen
this when the girls are wearing fake
boobs that are this big dicks like that
mm-hmm I'm not into it
you said you were hard I got a lot of
things make me hard though it doesn't
even deny it I didn't want it to more
information than what I even asked oh
that's for sure you had this things that
are you in the big titty ladies with the
juggernaut business okay you've been
hard on intentionally oh yeah for sure
from things that you don't even want to
know your uncle like mannequins in
downtown LA yeah yeah cuz they've got
those perky nipples yes mm-hmm
they don't have nipples she got from um
- oh yeah I'm just honest with myself
yeah you're very open very yes very open
open so I'm upset I
she's quoting people from you sometimes
nobody here thinks that I read comments
I say things that aren't true because in
the future they will be you're
manifesting destiny blog attraction yeah
know everything he says is true now I'm
confused
okay not long from now it will be a very
widely accepted first is just chicks
with huge [ __ ] thing it'll be a thing
right and we will be seen as barbarians
for the types of pornography that the
mundane types that we like now it's a
lot so he's a pioneer of this he is
indeed yes yeah he's an early you will
be [ __ ] laughed at Galileo you know
comprising news Isaac yep how the hell
yeah
and I'm always often misunderstood so
it's it's also that Rudolf so I'm glad
that there's finally someone here that's
willing to recognize me for all of the
things that I'm the vision area that you
are that you can also appreciate
XXXL titties you know what's sad Joe is
that we all just laughed again again but
you will be seen like Copernicus like
that laugh you guys will laugh like
Albert Einstein but that's why I stay
complex at all cuz I'm Isaac Newton
forget him and all these peasants over
here I don't want to say it no you said
it what the [ __ ] you've said enough
yeah no I mean I don't take the peasant
part but I'm short peasants yeah yeah
that's all I gotta say